the nursing members of Unison which is a
labor sporting unions have accepted the
latest offer from the government but of
course despite the advice from their own
leaders the RCN members have rejected it
are you disappointed by that I want to
enter this dispute like everyone else
we've still got two more unions who are
out balloting their members on the deal
so we wait and see what they say and you
know without speaking for the RCN that's
their job my sense from talking to
members who've been voting in this
ballot is the result that they've cast I
think reflects the depth of anger with
the government some of the rhetoric
we've seen from government ministers
during the dispute you know one point
um saying that nurses were helping
Vladimir Putin by going on strike I
think that sort of rhetoric hasn't
helped and my fear is that and I hope
this dispute has resolved imminently for
this year my fear is we're going to end
straight back here for the coming years
pay round so I think what the government
need to do more than anything else
actually is to give NHS staff some sense
of light the end of the tunnel so we're
not back here month after month year
after year because reading the headlines
about a year of industrial action
patients can't afford it the NHS can't
afford it I actually don't think staff
themselves can afford it in terms of the
pay they lose so we've got to have a
resolution that's that's a government
but um for once the opposition could
have an influence here would you like to
take this opportunity to appeal to RCN
members to follow the Unison colleagues
and think again well they've obviously
had their vote one thing I would say to
RCN they're talking about an escalation
of the dispute through the manner of the
strike action they've taken I think one
of the reasons why the RCN has enjoyed
widespread public support is that in
previous rounds of industrial action
they have been gone out of their way in
fact to say look we're going to protect
emergency care we're going to protect
Cancer Care and I'm deeply worried about
the risk of escalation of the nature of
their dispute to remove what none of the
derogations the measures they put in
Place protect those areas of care I'd
appeal to them if they are going on
strike again to continue to protect
patient care because with the junior
doctors strikes this week we'll see what
the actual impact of that was in the
coming days but I am really worried
about patient safety actually in the
middle of all of this so for absolute
Clarity you think it would be wrong for
the RCN to escalate by removing the
protect the protection for emergency
life-saving care that they extended in
previous strikes yeah there just aren't
circumstances in which I'm going to sit
on your program and say I think it's
right to remove cover for emergency care
for Cancer Care I think that would be
the wrong thing to do I think the
government of Got to Now
um you know bend over backwards to
resolve the disputes not just in
relation to nurses by the way but Junior
doctors because they're making the same
mistakes all over again we saw months
and months of no negotiation with
nursing which led to disruption but also
a tremendous amount of bad will and bad
feeling towards the government in the
nursing profession they're making the
same mistakes all over again with Junior
doctors now where even after four days
of strike action this week which was far
more disruptive than the nurses strike
there are still no negotiations and I
cannot for the life of me understand why
today we've got the health secretary
writing and the sun saying he's worried
about patient safety well you know it's
no point writing to a newspaper like an
Agony Aunt you're the health secretary
show some leadership well let's talk
let's talk about that the Jews and
doctors pay demands around about 35
percent
it'll cost one uh 1.65 billion gross uh
Labor's always very keen to tell the
government to get around the table let's
suppose you're the health secretary and
you're around this mythical table
would you accept the 35 uh
Demand Being on the table would you
accept that that something that you
would negotiate at that level well I've
been very upfront with the BMA and
saying that a 35 demand is not something
that I would be able to deliver if I
were the health secretary today
around the table because they're saying
they're not coming to the table unless
the 35 percent is on the table I'm not
sure that they are saying that I heard
them
to be fair of the BMA and we're not
always on critical of each other I think
what they've said is they've made their
35 pay claim they've explained why
they've reached that figure but they
what they have said is they're not
setting preconditions for talks and I
think one of the things that we've
surely got to have learned from the
nurses strike is don't set preconditions
for talks just sit around the table and
talk and negotiate and let's see if you
can try and meet someone the
government's position of no compromise
and the bmas position which is 35 but
willingness to come so this is a message
to the junior doctors which is to say
drop the insistence that the government
must uh have the 35 quote on the table
and to the government uh drop all
preconditions basically what you're
saying is everybody stop saying I've
come to the table if yes drop
preconditions just sit down and
negotiate because it's not in patients
interest for this disruptions continue
it's also not in the interests of Staff
you know NHS staff on picket lines do
not want to be there they want to be at
work serving their patients what they do
want I think is fair pay and some light
at the end of the tunnel that the
terrible conditions they're working in
the NHS are going to improve in the
foreseeable future and I think it's that
sense of hopelessness and Desperation
that's been reflected in the balance
results that we're seeing
um now uh the the the doctors have been
pretty clear about what they what they
want you've also been clear that a labor
government would demand reform uh if it
were do dealing with the situation now
um the uh one of the doctor's leaders
BMA chair Philip Banfield was on this
program a few weeks ago um here's what
he said about you he said I met with
West streeting this week and we had to
agree to disagree that he doesn't
understand general practice uh labor has
a lot of work to do between now and an
election we've offered to help them with
that and we'll do business with anyone
who has the right policies now um do you
feel any more clued up about general
practice uh since you've met him has he
given you a little seminar let me tell
you what I see in general practice which
is despite a million more appointments
being provided by GP since pre-pandemic
levels we still have a situation where
people are struggling to get access to a
GP still scrambling to get through at
8am in the morning to book an
appointment as if we're still living in
the 20th century rather than the 21st
and people often especially those with
ongoing medical conditions uh
struggling to see not just a doctor but
the same doctor for that continuity of
care
and we've got to change the situation
for patients primarily but also for
people working in general practice so I
think are increasingly burned out and
demoralized and what I see in the NHS at
the moment as a system is the worst of
all worlds which is we do late diagnosis
which means both more expensive and less
effective if I'm going to say so you're
telling me about diagnosis that's not
what you want to do but what we want to
do is shift the focus of healthcare out
the hospital into the community more
Primary Care to do that of course you
need to have the staff that's why we've
committed to the biggest expansion of
NHS staff in history doubling the number
of medical school places as the NHS has
asked for as well as increasing nursing
and Midwifery clinical training place
and a whole range of other staff roles
okay because unless we've got the
doctors we need we're not going to get
all right I know you're going to tell me
that you'll pay for that with a non-dom
tax
um just very quickly the non-dom tax by
my Reckoning is now paying for your
seven and a half thousand doctors it's
also paying for breakfast clubs in
schools I think it's also paying for um
police officers now of course you can
get into a room and fight with Yvette
Cooper that's the two two things
how much is this uh this is a kind of
magical expanding no it's not isn't it
no it's not I'm glad you asked this
question so two things it's paying for
it's paying for the biggest expansion of
NHS staff in history 1.6 billion pounds
is paying for the expansion of Primary
School breakfast clubs to every primary
school and that's met within the more
than three billion pound spending yeah
that that provides and all of Labor's
policies at the next election are going
to be fully closed and the windfall of
taxes paying for everything else is it
the windfall tax is obviously paying for
measures to help with people's energy
bills which is the right thing to do
okay and there is a running theme here
Trevor which is not only are our
policies fully costed and fully funded
but there's fairness baked into how we
pay for it because under the
conservatives we've got the worst of all
worlds which is working people being
clobbered with higher taxes that they
can't really afford and we've gone from
low growth to zero growth in the economy
under the conservatives okay okay there
is a question about whether there'll be
any non-doms left because the numbers
are shrinking everything
we always hear this
on working people let's go effortlessly
but the moment you say let's ask people
with broad shoulders to pay the
conservatives start crying
but they can't afford it I mean Cry Me a
River I'm just I'm just making an
observation that the numbers of are
shrinking 10 year by year because every
time you say we're going to tax you they
decide not to come here let's talk about
let's talk about Labor Zone let's talk
about Labor Zone campaign
um you put out this ad campaign
attacking Rishi sunak uh on a series of
fronts
um
was that a mistake no here we are here
here we are I mean do you genuinely you
wear streaking do you genuinely believe
that that man there thinks that adults
convicted of sexually assaulting
children should not go should not go to
prison well if you believe that no don't
tell me what you what you meant do you
believe that well
it doesn't believe that no no no why
have we believe that we'll ask Rishi
soon that because he lets four and a
half thousand adults convicted of
sexually assaulting children under 16.
I'm asking you you've met this guy do
you think he actually thinks that people
who have sexually assaulted children
I'd like to believe that the answer is
no but look at the figures speak for
themselves why is he allowing this to
happen and it's perfectly reasonable to
challenge a conservative prime minister
on the abysmal failure of 13 years no no
you you keep Sliding Away From what your
poster says which is that this guy
thinks that people who have assaulted
well there are only should not should
not go to prison tell me well there are
no answer to this question do you think
he thinks that or do you not think he
thinks that well I have to assume that
he thinks that because otherwise it's
either it's either that or incompetence
isn't it
either human being either he thinks it
either he thinks it which is bad or he
doesn't think it but isn't doing
anything about it which is equally bad
either he's got the wrong uh policies
and principles or he's just incompetent
and can't deliver and either I think is
a problem for the prime minister of the
country and labor is absolutely right to
take the gloves off and hold the
government's account for 13 years of
appalling failure on Law and Order in
the economy in our Public Services
nothing is working properly in this
country after 13 years of conservative
government and we're right to hold them
over to the college say Labor's taken to
set out an alternative you say Labor's
taking off the gloves let's um look at
what that um well-known softy labor
former labor Home Secretary David
blunkett said he said when I heard
yesterday about a tweet from the labor
party's official account suggesting that
Richardson was somehow responsible for
failing to lock up criminals who had
abused children I immediately thought my
party is better than this uh David
blunkett well-known
you know kind of soft-hearted uh
wouldn't would never get into the ring
with the opposition come on boy come on
this is an opportunity for you to say
look this was a mistake
I don't think it was a mistake at all
absolutely
there's more to come there's more to
come we're going to get more of this are
we yep we're good robustly holding the
government to account for 13 years of
failure and Rishi sunak doesn't get away
with coming in at the last minute
through as to replace yet another
failing conservative prime minister to
pretend that somehow he's a clean slate
that he's different from everything
that's come before because we've had now
enough chances enough Prime Ministers
under the conservative party what we
haven't got are results that deliver for
the country and we're right to hold them
to account and right to set out a labor
alternative we're streaking thank you
very much thanks have me